the robots are coming for our jobs they
pick our jobs AI is going to put all of
the artists out of work well maybe maybe
not but AI is already here and it's
raising all kinds of ethical and legal
questions should AI be able to get a
copyright over the work that it produces
what would that even mean and if the AI
doesn't own the copyright who does own
the copyright and what about trading in
AI using someone else's work such that
the AI can produce new works of art that
look exactly like the kind of style that
a real human artist would produce that's
my exact style well we're going to
explore all of that today and we're
going to start with the idea of whether
an AI can have a copyright in something
and well usually on this channel I say
something like it depends or it's
complicated depends on the circumstances
the answer here is actually pretty
clear-cut and the answer is no an AI
cannot under the current law own any
kind of copyright in the work that it
produces why because copyright is
reserved solely for human authors under
the current Copyright Act the only thing
that can get a copyright is an original
work of authorship and courts have
interpreted the term authorship to mean
a human author the most famous case that
involves this particular issue is
probably the so-called monkey selfie
case of Naruto versus Slater where
macaque monkey got a hold of a
photographer's camera pressed the
shutter button and was able to take a
photo of itself the organization Peta
tried to litigate the case claiming that
the monkey was actually the author and
not the cameraman and thus the monkey
had certain rights to the photo the
courts pretty much universally said no
anyone other than a human person cannot
have a copyright and cannot be the
author for the purposes of the Copyright
Act and the answer is no if you're
asking the question in your head can a
computer be considered a human person
computers are not people at least not
for the time being
now an additional issue is that for
something to receive a copyright the
work has to be considered minimally
creative and expressive there's a
threshold for the minimum amount of
creativity that needs to go in to work
for it to be considered copyrightable
and this question goes all the way back
to a case from the 19th century called
burgiles lithography versus Cerrone that
involved the question of whether a
photograph could be copyrighted now
today we take that for granted that of
course all photographs whether on film
or digital are going to be a
copyrightable form of expression but
back in the day this was an open
question and people argued that a
photograph simply portrays things as
they actually appear in real life but
the Supreme Court and now this has been
incorporated into the Copyright Act
assume that a photograph taken by a
photographer is going to have a kind of
minimal creativity that's necessary for
copyright ability whether it's in the
framing the settings used on the camera
posing of subjects the selection of the
subject itself all of that reaches some
minimal amount of creativity and when it
comes to AI generated work whether
you're talking about a painting a video
or something in text odds are the courts
are going to say that that is not
minimally creative to the point where it
can be copyrighted because it was a
computer that did the creation not an
actual human and there have been several
instances where people have tried to
generate art using Ai and then register
that work with the copyright office and
they have disclosed to the copyright
office that it was entirely generated by
artificial intelligence and in those
cases the copyright office has denied a
copyright in those particular Works
citing the lack of human authorship and
expressive creativity and in one very
interesting instance someone actually
used an AI to generate an entire comic
book based on various prompts that they
provided they actually did get a
copyright in that work but now having
realized that the work was entirely AI
generated the copyright office is trying
to strip the copyright from that
particular comic book and we'll see what
happens there but at the same time this
isn't a binary dichotomy this is a
spectrum on one end of the spectrum you
have something that is entirely
generated by Ai and on the other end of
the spectrum you have something that is
entirely generated by a person but
there's all kinds of ways for people to
use artificial intelligence as a tool
and at the moment it's entirely unclear
at which point the court will say that's
enough human creativity to Warrant a
copyright for example I can imagine that
if I'm doing something in Photoshop and
I use the content aware fill where I
delete out a section of a photo and have
the computer replace it for me if I
leave most of the photograph intact I
assume that I'd still be able to get a
copyright in that particular photo and
it's at what point where I'm not really
putting something in as an input the AI
takes over and the court says no you
can't get a copyright in that that's
going to be litigated many many times in
the future and we'll see where the
chords come out but a lot of people are
also upset about the way that AIS are
trained and we've seen several instances
where if you train an AI on a data set
of a particular author or painter's work
the AI does a pretty good job of being
able to replicate the style of that
artist's work and create new works in
that original author's style and
generally speaking you can't have a
copyright over a particular style but
you can get a copyright in in individual
works of expression but is it fair or
ethical or legal to be able to train an
AI using a data set that includes
copyrighted work because it seems like
most AIS are pretty much useless until
they've been trained on a very large
data set and usually that involves
scraping large portions of the internet
of copyrighted work and if that sounds
like copyright infringement well it
probably is reproducing someone's work
and taking it from one area of the
internet and putting it into a data set
is often going to involve what would
technically be considered copyright
infringement but that doesn't really end
the analysis because often even though
something might be considered copyright
infringement in the first instance you
might have a fair use defense and as it
happens there are a couple of
potentially analogous cases that involve
scraping the internet to form large data
sets that might provide the backbone for
a fair use defense for all of these
researchers who are creating huge data
sets and then training an AI on it the
two most famous of these cases involve
Google and the first case is called
Perfect 10 verse is Google that involved
Google the search engine scraping
basically the entire internet including
images and then producing thumbnails in
search results smaller versions of the
original images now Perfect 10 was a
website that
how do I put this made money by selling
access to photos and I'll let you use
your imagination as to what kinds of
photos people would pay lots of money
for they didn't like that Google was
scraping their particular website and
displaying thumbnails of the images that
were contained on the perfect 10 website
they claimed that this was copyright
infringement and they sued Google over
it the courts went back and forth but
eventually the courts found that Google
while it was effectively conducting
copyright infringement because the
thumbnails were used for a different
purpose than the original images Google
was allowed to do that effectively the
search function and display of those
smaller thumbnails was not the same
purpose that people were using the
original images for the second similar
case is called the Google Books case
which is the author's Guild versus
Google and again Google was compiling a
huge data set of basically every book
ever written and then allowed people to
search through that database the
author's Guild was not thrilled with the
ability of Google to search through all
of these these different books Google
argued that it had a fair use purpose in
being able to facilitate people looking
through all of these books and again
they weren't displaying the entire book
itself but instead just small Snippets
of where the particular phrase or word
showed up within a particular book
itself and again the court sided with
Google and while the initial formation
of this data set and reproduction of
these books might qualify as copyright
infringement the court said that Google
was allowed to get away with this search
and display because its purpose was for
fair use purposes red
beautiful you're pushing your luck
little man
though that analogy does break down
because in both of the Google cases what
Google was doing was fairly descriptive
it was essentially just describing what
was already there AI is different it's
generated it is generating something new
based on prior works and that might run
a foul we don't entirely know what the
court is going to decide when it comes
to True AI generation of work based on a
data set the same kind of fair use
defense that Google might have in a
descriptive context might not apply in
an AI generative context we just simply
don't know you know something nothing
for you come back one year there are
good arguments on both sides one might
say that what an AI does is pretty
similar to what the Google search
function does one might also argue that
effectively what the AI is doing is what
every single human in the world is doing
they are experiencing art in the world
and they are mixing that with their own
skills to create a new work of art
though at the same time it's entirely
possible that this will be solved
statutorily that we might have a carve
out in the law that says while humans
are of course doing the same process if
an algorithm in an AI is doing it we're
going to say that's not allowable and
there is no fair use defense these laws
can always be changed and that takes us
to perhaps the strangest situation of
all which is that as we discussed an AI
can't have a copyright in a work that it
generates and it's likely that the
people who program the AI also don't get
a copyright in the works that the AI
generates but that doesn't solve the
issue of copyright infringement because
just because you don't own a copyright
in something doesn't mean that you
didn't commit copyright infringement so
say say for example I tell an AI text to
image generator that I wanted to produce
a cartoon of a mouse wearing red shorts
and it happens to produce a photograph
that looks strikingly similar to Mickey
Mouse I didn't ask it to produce
something that looks like Mickey Mouse I
probably don't own the copyright in that
image and neither does the AI generator
and yet that image still probably
infringes on the copyright of Disney
because it looks exactly like Mickey
Mouse who's liable for the copyright
infringement in that particular
situation it's sort of anyone's guess
copyright infringement tends to be a
pretty strict liability offense
theoretically maybe the programmer is
liable theoretically maybe the person
who provided the prompt itself certainly
if I were to go and reproduce that image
and publish it then I would certainly be
liable for the copyright infringement
but there's all kinds of unintended
consequences that are potentially
possible here that we don't necessarily
have a good answer for and speaking of
unintended consequences right on
schedule the loss suits are starting to
pour in there are already several
interesting lawsuits testing out these
copyright issues the first wave of
lawsuits for taking aim at a process
developed by stability AI which created
a generative tool called diffusion where
the program is first trained to be able
to reconstruct images that it has been
fed then it generates new images in
response to a written prompt stable
diffusion is now being used by several
companies including deviantART and
mid-journey Getty Images officially
notified stability AI of its intent to
sue the company in the United Kingdom
for unlawfully scraping millions of
images from its site which could violate
UK's standard of fair dealing a
stability AI copied and processed
millions of Getty Images to train its
software and whereas most AI companies
are secretive about where they get their
data stable diffusion is transparent the
open source software allowed Andy Bayo
and Simon Wilson to analyze the the
training data set they found that a
large number of the images came from
stock image sites including 123 RF
Shutterstock Vector stock and Getty
among others and sometimes the AI even
recreated a facsimile of the Getty
Watermark it is lawsuit was filed in a
high court of justice in London and the
company didn't say whether they were
going to also file a lawsuit in the
United States however in a press release
the company argued that stability's
actions did not meet the standard for
fair use in the U.S Getty argues that
it's in the same position as the artist
whose music was illegally shared through
services like Napster Getty claims that
it's not trying to shut the company down
only that they're trying to create some
sort of license agreement similar to
Spotify which negotiates licenses with
its rights holders meanwhile visual
artists filed a class action lawsuit
against stability Ai mid-journey and
deviantART the three named plaintiffs
are artists whose work has been used to
train AI tools Sarah Anderson is the
creator of the webcomic Sarah scribbles
Kelly mckernan is an illustrator for
games Books and Comics and Carla Ortiz
is a concept artist in illustrator who
has worked for Marvel film studios and
Wizards of the Coast the complaint was
filed in California and it alleges that
the three companies committed copyright
infringement by using images owned by
the artist to train their image
generators and produce derivative works
the plaintiffs also assert claims under
the dmca in unfair competition laws now
only the copyright owner has the right
to make or authorize an adaptation of
the original the plaintiff's claimed
that the image generators are simply
21st century collage tools that enable
users to make unlicensed derivative
works but the lawsuit's characterization
of AI generated art as a collage seems
like an oversimplification but who knows
what kind of analogies the court might
use to Parson understand this new
technology and its implications it's an
open question whether the generated
images would qualify as a derivative or
not and they're good arguments on either
side but the plaintiffs are probably
going to run into some of the issues
that we already discussed earlier in
this video images are protected by
copyright but an artist's style is not
generally issues of copyright
infringement are decided on an image by
image basis now the Anderson versus
stability AI lawsuit claims quote when
used to produce images from prompts by
its user stable diffusion uses the
training images to produce seemingly new
images through a mathematical software
process these quote new images are based
entirely on the training images and are
derivative works of the particular
images stable diffusion draws from when
assembling a given output ultimately it
is merely a complex collage tool now
this section of the plaintiff's
complaint really gets to the head of the
argument the plaintiffs are claiming
that everything generated by AI is a
derivative now a derivative work is an
independently copyrightable work it is
based on a prior work so for example
compare the movie Jurassic Park to the
book Jurassic Park the original novel
had a copyright Michael Crichton had a
total control over the novel and also
anyone who wanted to make a movie so
Steven Spielberg had to get a license
from Creighton to make that movie which
was a derivative work
[Applause]
now the technical definition of
derivative is quote a work based upon
one or more pre-existing works such as a
translation fictionalization Motion
Picture version sound recording art
reproduction abridgement condensation or
any other form in which a work may be
recast transformed or adapted now notice
the Copyright Act says a derivative is
transformed
now this can get very confusing because
if you know anything about fair use
transformed or transformative is
basically the same standard now the
movie Jurassic Park definitely
transformed the original novel
but that doesn't mean it's necessarily a
fair use quite the opposite in fact and
for the affirmative defense of fair use
to apply it has to be transformative at
a minimum but it also has to be for a
separate purpose that the courts
recognize as allowable I'll allow it it
also must be the other four fair use
factors and it gets even more
complicated as one commentator put it
the term derivative work in a technical
sense does not refer to all works that
borrow in any degree from pre-existing
Works a work is not derivative unless it
has substantially copied from prior work
if what is borrowed consists merely of
ideas and not the expression of ideas
then although the work may have in part
been derived from prior works it is not
a derivative work and as one chord put
it in Truth in literature in science and
in art there are and can be few if any
things which in abstract sense are
strictly new and original throughout
read a book every book in literature
science and art borrows and must
necessarily borrow and use much which
was known and used before if no book
could be the subject of copyright which
was not new an original in the elements
of which it is composed there could be
no ground for any copyright in Modern
Times And we would be obliged to ascend
very high even in Antiquity defined work
entitled to such Eminence Virgil
borrowed from Homer bacon Drew from
earlier as well as contemporary Minds
Coke exhausted all the known learning of
his profession and even Shakespeare in
Milton would be found to have gathered
much from the Abundant stores of current
knowledge and classical studies in their
days it's all to believe today but but
that
place and really that's the rub in this
particular copyright lawsuit and lots of
others because not everything that's art
is new original or protectable it
depends and the stability AI lawsuit
goes on to say quote until now when a
purchaser seeks a new image in the style
of a given artist they must pay to
commission or license an original image
from that artist now strictly speaking
that's just wrong artists don't get
protection over their Styles you can
absolutely go to another artist and say
I want you to paint an image in the
style of another artist but of a
completely different subject and if you
did that would not be copyright
infringement you don't have to pay to
commission an original artist to do
something in another artist's Style with
rare exceptions so for example if Van
Gogh paintings were still under
copyright if you went to another artist
who was not Vincent van Gogh and said I
want a painting of a robot on a Starship
in the style of Starry Night you would
not have to pay a commission to Van Gogh
you don't get protection over that kind
of of style and that's one of the
non-intuitive things about copyright you
could absolutely copy something but if
the result looks nothing like the
original then it's not copyright
infringement for example imagine I'm a
painter and I'm trying to make a copy of
the Mona Lisa I have the Mona Lisa
directly in front of me and I try to
copy it but I'm such a terrible painter
that it basically just turned out a
smiley face now I literally tried to
copy another work but I also basically
failed and even though I actually copied
it it's not infringement because my
painting looks nothing like the original
Mona Lisa assuming the Mona Lisa was
still under copyright and that's because
the standard for copyright infringement
is usually explained something like this
a plaintiff must first show that the
work was actually copied second they
must establish substantial similarity or
that the copying amounts to an improper
or unlawful appropriation now it's a
whole ball game as to what constitutes
unlawful appropriation but usually goes
something like it was protectable
expression of the earlier work that was
copied and that the amount that was
copied was more than and de minimis more
than just the minimal amount that law
doesn't actually approve of it gets
extremely complicated but now I think
you can see a lot of the actual issues
at play was there actual copying for the
databases that were used to train the AI
yes and that's copyright infringement
unless there was a fair use defense and
there could be under the perfect 10 in
authors Guild cases and then the
additional issue of is art that is
generated by AI based on these trained
images is that necessarily a derivative
work and does that infringe on the
original Works copyright and that's an
open question too maybe but probably not
and that's because copyright is almost
always done on a case-by-case basis you
have to look at one image and compare it
to the original image and only then
generally speaking can you make a
determination as to whether there is
copyright infringement generally you
can't say I'm looking at the process and
not looking at the output to make a
determination that everything generated
by this process is necessarily
infringement The Defenders here might
can see that there was actual copying
but that's not the end of the discussion
that's merely the beginning of the
discussion and speaking of which that's
also just the beginning of AI
Shenanigans because there's one guy who
claims that he can replace lawyers with
AI chat Bots now that's super dumb so I
made a whole video about how dumb that
is and thanks to the power of today's
sponsor nebula you can watch my video
about that right now even though it'll
be weeks before I release it on YouTube
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we've just lost the
picture but what we've seen speaks for
itself it's already available to watch
on nebula because my videos always go up
on nebula first Plus on nebula there's
tons of exclusive content for example
when you sign up for nebula directly you
get access to nebula classes which
includes my entire course how to sue
like a lawyer that used to be hundreds
of dollars a year but now it's free and
included with your direct nebula
subscription and that's just one of tons
of exclusive videos that are available
only on nebula and iMac exclusive
content all the time because what's
truly special about nebula is it is a
creator-owned platform built by me and
other YouTubers and because it's a
subscription service we get to work on
larger higher budget Productions than we
ever could on YouTube and some of my
absolute favorite videos and it's almost
all nebula first or nebula exclusive and
if you sign up using my link that's on
screen right now or down in the
description you'll get a 10 discount a
year which means it'll cost you only
three dollars and 33 cents each month
you'll get access to my videos early get
access to exclusives and you'll be able
to support the ambitious projects that
my friends and I are working on and our
own streaming site so set up right now
by clicking on the button button that's
on screen right now or click on the link
that's down below in the description to
get a huge discount for nebula and after
that click on this box over here for
more legal eagle where I'll see you in
court